thank you fireworks Los Angeles is known
for its amazing Asian cuisine and I'm
gonna take the other try guys on a trip
around town some surprise locations
where they're gonna try some extreme
Asian dishes oh you're doing torturing
us I'm gonna try to eat as little food
as possible you know why cuz I got a
fucked-up tongue secret's out everybody
I got geographic tongue I feel like the
three dishes I've chosen cover
everything from creepy to slimy - spicy
dry guys cease mode Asian food extreme
adventure something all right so the
first restaurant buoyancy was this
awesome place called typhoon it's a man
Asian fusion restaurants you're gonna be
eating bugs what what kind of bugs cuz
lobsters or bugs my stomach because it's
a stupid car is what hi my name is Brian
vidura and I am the owner of typhoon
here at the Santa Monica Airport so you
were working in Asia and you moved over
here in open typhoon yeah you were
inspired by some of the different snacks
and street foods in Asia Street we've
got yes
yeah the crickets were in Taipei beer
gardens and the silkworm Koopas are from
Thailand we're getting more and more
people coming here and for the bugs they
taste would be good so these are
Taiwanese style crickets I had a lizard
growing up who ain't crickets maybe that
just like this that's a big old plane a
bug it's gonna be each other
sure oh no that's great almost like
eating the skin off a fried chicken got
a leg in the back of my throat for a
second
they keep jumping sound of my chopstick
extremeness I'm gonna say like one
not that extreme no I would eat this as
a snap thumbs are beautiful whoa whoa
they look like little chicken nuggets I
don't know if they were right chicken
nuggets they look like bugs
ribbed for her pleasure oh so these are
really popular in a lot of Asian
countries especially in Korea where we
call them boom diggy diggy oh it just
bursts it just tastes a lot like corn
tasty wet hay oh I could see a horse
just doing a bigger worm baby
holy [ __ ] you can kind of see through it
oh it's not the most pleasant experience
bugs overall sort of extreme decently
tasty and always looks like a plate of
bugs we let the bug place what's next
we're doing a water creature of some
sort okay like a lobster we go options
there's no more sucking some sort of
[ __ ] fish we are going to reach live
octopus Oh
guys why was the octopus laughing why is
he had tentacles let's go eat one all
right guys we are here in Koreatown at
masada restaurants and in a lot of
Korean and Japanese cuisine things are
so fresh there so basically alive this
looks crazy
so sea urchin or Unni is quite expensive
so now at the same right yeah that's a
delicacy dad's but it looks like the top
of a
good sexy starfish you know some
surfaces look shitty alright it's like
buttery I don't know what I just tasted
butter coming through really complicated
it's kind of just like if melon was a
meat what lobsters blood tastes like I
like to call this the foie gras of the
ocean who would have thought there'd be
something so good inside this coffee
straw coconut no do you have anything to
get this a stain out the video can wait
okay I don't want this to stain so the
best part is you can just like we were
toothpick I mean it look it's hardcore
it's not extreme but it is an animal and
we are eating its gonads all right one
of my favorite dishes sannakji which is
what we call live octopus it's recently
a live octopus does it move it
this is especially prevalent in Korea
Japan
oh that's eyeball ha ha ha look you
gotta win Monica oh that feels so weird
oh I don't want a new head go to [ __ ]
my bro Oh wouldn't I go away with how's
it taste
it's really chewy it's like seafood gum
it's actually delicious
I mean you can't get Rohrer than this no
this is the freshest food I've ever had
the most extreme thing I've ever eaten
I'm afraid that's all of this big one
you guys there's one more restaurant
right I feel like I feel like it trying
to like grab onto my chest I know I
think it's like it's trying to work its
way back up my esophagus I'm still gonna
eating it what is that we had we had
bugs we arrived we had sea creatures
yeah and now we're gonna do something
pretty tame you know something pretty
temp in Manali yeah just the spiciest
dish in Los Angeles
Eugene my tongues [ __ ] up so we're
going to a Thai restaurant called
Jitlada I love gelada we know that you
guys have something called the dynamite
challenge yes just you guys choose try
this when it goes spicy how spicy are we
talking one to ten yeah ten being the
biggest ten I'm nervous I'm anxious we
both love spicy food I basically grew up
on spicy food
I've chosen a piece that like has no
visible spice to put more spice on I'll
put more spice on and just um before you
guys start keep this screaming - like Oh
minimally yeah Eugene will keep our
screaming to a minimum if you wanted to
stick holding our mouth
shouldn't we go oh I think I'm gonna
vomit Oh delicious flavor oh now it's
getting worse it's getting the most
preposterous dish in Los Angeles
I'm giving cunnilingus to a piece of
cucumber that's how much pain I'm in a
my credit crying am i sweating
thank your all diseases if I eat them
maybe I will be curious weapon deer
Jitlada you're dynamite challenge was
the last stop in our extreme Asian food
tour we regret everything but we love
you I can't stop burping and farting
Zach crying Eugene dying Keith of the
Thai guys
this was just the battle the war will be
waged of my toilet all night it's a good
thing my wife's out of town my fun
Italian foods next I'm Italian Italians
have very interesting cuisine like pasta
yeah my friends left